i
ah
[Música]
a
la reanudación de la liga de campeones
trajo esperanza no solamente a los
hinchas del fútbol sino a la gente en
general porque es una manera de que la
vida retome el curso una vez más de
nuevo después de meses de confinamiento
por causa del coronavirus en el mundo
entero lisboa ganó el privilegio de
acoger las fases finales de la liga de
campeones de acoger a los 8 mejores
equipos de europa por el buen manejo de
la pandemia que ha tenido portugal aquí
en europa y en realidad pues en el mundo
entero y es una manera también para que
el lisboa pues se saque a relucir esa
carta como una de las ciudades
turísticas en el mundo por excelencia
sin embargo no se ven grandes multitudes
aquí en el lisboa no se espera que haya
unos 16.000 personas que vengan en el
marco de esta liga de campeones pero aún
los turistas no regresan en masa como
suele ser en cada verano además de esto
pues en los partidos se juegan a puerta
cerrada no hay público lo cual quiere
decir que los hinchas que han venido los
pocos hinchas que han venido tanto
alemanes como franceses por ejemplo pues
pueden
los partidos en bares y restaurantes
pero eso es todo sin embargo se espera
que la liga de campeones- traigo unas
ganancias de unos 50 millones de euros a
la capital de portugal
[Música]
la federación de tenis de eeuu ha
confirmado un caso positivo de
coronavirus en el usopen después de
realizar más de 1400 pruebas de kobe 19
esa persona que no se trata de un
jugador ya ha sido puesta en cuarentena
y ahora se están analizando a todos
aquellos que pudieron tener contacto con
ella la organización está intentando
crear una especie de burbuja al igual
que lo ha hecho la nba para mantener
controlados en cualquier momento tanto a
jugadores a equipo técnico a médicos y
periodistas tanto el torneo de
cincinnati como el usopen se van a
celebrar en un mismo lugar en nueva york
para evitar desplazamientos y también
que se puedan crear focos de infección a
pesar de todas las medidas de seguridad
algunas grandes figuras del tenis como
el español rafael nadal el francés gael
monfils o el suizo están va a brincar ya
han dicho que no van a participar del
torneo
[Música]
las principales ligas de fútbol de
américa latina' ya han recuperado su
actividad sin embargo grandes
competiciones como la argentina o la
colombiana todavía están a la espera
esta semana en colombia la dimayor el
ministerio de salud y la federación de
fútbol acordaron que la competición
puede pasar a la fase 4 del protocolo
esto significa el retorno de los
entrenamientos colectivos la antesala
para pasar a fase 5 y que vuelva a la
liga continuando desde el punto en el
que fue interrumpida el 10 de marzo el
presidente de la liga de fútbol fernando
jaramillo puso como fecha límite de
regreso el 15 de septiembre precisamente
en esa fecha está programada la vuelta
de la fase de grupos de la copa
libertadores la máxima competición del
fútbol sudamericano por su parte a nivel
de selecciones está previsto que el
fútbol vuelva en octubre con las
eliminatorias clasificatorias para el
mundial 2022 de qatar